guten abend herr steinberg ja wir haben
es gerade gesehene rückstaus an den
grenzen die von deutschland dicht
gemacht worden sind und der bayerische
ministerpräsident und der
csu-generalsekretär werfen ihnen nun vor
dass österreich verantwortlich dafür ist
dass die mutation sich ausbreitet weil
nicht genug dagegen getan worden ist hat
sogar damit recht das gefühl dass sogar
zurückfallen die schlimmste zeit vom
märz 2020 und damals haben wir seine
immer verstanden dass wir unterscheiden
zwischen güter für zwischen wirtschaft
und notwendigen wir gemäß notwendige
einschränkung der mobilität was jetzt
momentan geschieht geht meiner meinung
nach darüber hinaus und ich glaube wir
müssen wir wieder im lot finden mast
hinten weil genau was sie geschrieben
haben vor der tschechischen grenze und
italienisch österreich und
österreichisch deutschen grenze das sind
eigentlich sehen die schon hinter uns
gedacht haben
sie sagen gerade man muster wieder ein
load finden also eine gemeinsame mitte
finden sie haben jetzt den deutschen
botschafter einbestellt warum was soll
das dann bringen was wünschen sie sich
soll jetzt an den grenzen passieren
bestellt habe ich ihn nicht sondern es
war sozusagen die einladung zu einem
gespräch wir versuchen auf allen ebenen
unsere botschaft in berlin natürlich
hier wird die botschaft ich selber mit
meinen kollegen heiko maas der hessische
innenminister ist wirtschaftsminister
denen das auf allen ebenen sich hier
seit tagen tätig in wirklichkeit kann
man sagen haben wir drei problembereiche
rheine ist transit durch tirol und das
ist einer der wesentlichen features aber
die europäischen kontinent geschlecht
hin wenn man sich überlegt was da
durchfährt und durch rollt in südafrika
seitens für uns natürlich sehr
wesentlich aber bitte auch für
deutschland der pendlerverkehr es gibt
immerhin mehr deutsche männer nach tirol
als umgekehrt
wo wir derzeit noch das damoklesschwert
haben über uns welche betriebe sind
systemrelevant welche arbeitnehmer in
diesem betrieb kriegen 100 bescheinigung
wir sind montag haben mittwochs gelten
es ist immer noch nicht
und der dritte punkt ist uns auch sehr
schmerzhaft
der transit durch deutschland von
österreich aus österreich also sozusagen
die fahrt von tirol nach salzburg über
was wir in österreich das deutsche eck
nenne ich höre dass er gespräche zu
einer pragmatischen lösung führen können
und dass sie hier
öffnungen erreichen könne aber das sind
drei konkrete problem punkte die hatten
wir haben sich schon in den letzten
monaten immer wieder geklärt und es ist
schmerzlich dass wir hier schon mal
wieder zurückfallen und wieder vom neuen
die lernkurve zusagen zurück fallen
trotzdem die angst vor der korona
mutation diese ist ja noch relativ neu
und hier in deutschland sorgt sie auch
dafür dass viele maßnahmen noch
verstärkt worden sind was wäre denn dann
ein schritt der jetzt sowohl für
deutschland österreich andere
nachbarländer der richtige gemeinsam
wäre um diese mutation trotzdem so gut
wie möglich aufhalten zu können also nur
damit ich nicht missverstanden werde es
ist völlig legitim dass man hier maßen
setzt wie in österreich haben sie selber
gemacht und das war ein sehr
schmerzlicher schritt weil es gegen um
ein sehr wesentliches bundesland von
österreich also es ist legitim dass und
maßnahmen setzt zum schutz der
gesundheit wir uns besser geschafft
schutz der gesundheit und soweit es
irgend geht schutz der wirtschaft hand
in hand gehen so das so ich glaube dass
jetzt einige maße und hier überschießen
sehen und man sich vielleicht die
konsequenzen zum teil gar nicht wirklich
überlegt hat ist jedoch bemerkenswert
dass auch in frankreich sich schon
fragezeichen auf konten französischer
premierminister gesagt sie wollen auch
gewaltsam vor deutschen überraschungen
die eu-kommission sich anmeldet also ich
habe eine sehr gute gesprächsbasis mit
deutschland und ich baue darauf dass wir
doch jetzt pragmatische lösungen finden
zu diesen punkten
weil und schneidet sich in deutschland
lässt sich selber auch ins eigene
fleisch ein berg halten sie die
strategie der bundesregierung derzeit
führt zu überhaupt vorsichtig sie waren
jetzt die deutsche bundesregierung dann
ist man muss sich mal abwägen ich glaube
dass gewisse maßnahmen wie zum beispiel
zum transit oder zum durchfahrt von
österreich nach österreich durch
deutsche heck übertreten sind man möge
mir erklären
frächter der in mailand in den lkw stark
durch fertiger österreich ist münchen
sich da an stecken sollte das ist mir
leicht unerklärlich und natürlich für
das jetzt schon zu staus in italien weil
wir österreicher müssen sicherstellen
dass wir nach österreich heidfeld oder
ein an der deutschen grenze hängen
bleibt
damit ermöglicht tirol zum lkw hatte
europas das ist unser verhindert habe
also man sieht diese maßnahmen haben
sozusagen der lippenbewegungen quer
durch europa und das sind die eckpunkte
wo unsere deutschen freunde sich noch
einmal in sich gehen soll das überlegen
ist das auch im sinne des deutschen
welcher standorts nützen er ist mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schau dich hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren